bien mesdames messieurs
merci pour votre présence et l'écho que
vous pourrez réserver à notre prise de
position ce matin au travers les deux
présidents de groupe du Sénat Bruno
retaillot et de l'Assemblée Olivier
marlex notre secrétaire général Annie
jeunevard qui est par ailleurs
l'oratrice de notre groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale sur le projet de loi
immigration dans la nuit de vendredi à à
samedi la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté un texte
très largement revu
remaniier sur le projet de loi
immigration pour nous ce qu'a fait la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale correspond à une dégradation
très
majeur profonde des travaux qu'avait
réalisé le Sénat et des avancé qu'avait
porté le Sénat lors de la discussion du
texte sur
l'immigration nous avons posé à
l'ouverture de ces débats et nous
l'avons fait dès le printemps avec Bruno
rotaillot avec Olivier marlex des
principes très clairs en matière
d'immigration un nous voulons mettre fin
à une immigration de masse qui depuis
trop d'années déstabilise notre
organisation sociale et porte des
conséquences extrêmement graves pour la
cohésion de notre pays nous le voyons en
matière de montée du communautarisme
nous le voyons en matière de montée de
la violence nous le voyons aussi en
matière de terrorisme puisque la plupart
des faits de terrorisme qui ont
été commis depuis 2012 dans notre pays
sont directement à rattachés dans plus
de des 3/4 des cas à l'immigration de
première de 2e ou de 3e
génération prier principe mettre fin à
cette immigration de face 2ème principe
est c'est un moyen pour arriver au
premier c'est retrouver notre
souveraineté euh pour garder le contrôle
de notre territoire en matière
migratoire nous avons donc porté de deux
grands textes euh que nous avons déposé
dans les mêmes termes à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat un texte un projet
de loi simple un projet de loi
constitutionnel qui euh ont marqué nos
nos lignes de force nos principes notre
cap notre
direction c'est dans ce contexte que le
gouvernement nous a déjà opposé quelque
part une fin de non recevoir puisque il
aurait pu très bien s'il avait eu une
volonté de réelle négociation
d'ouverture d'avancer concrète il aurait
pu très bien discuter débattre sur les
bases de notre texte euh tel qu'il a été
euh déposé dans nos deux chambres il
aurait pu le faire notamment au Sénat il
a choisi de continuer à débattre du
texte initial du gouvernement c'est dans
ce contexte que le Sénat a
considérablement euh amélioré je dirais
et a abouti à un texte euh dont j'ai
salué euh euh la portée et qui marquait
des avancées très
concrète aussi loin je dirais qu'on
pouvait aller dans le cadre
constitutionnel actuel notre analyse
première c'est que le cadre
constitutionnel n'est plus adapté et ne
nous permet pas et ne nous permettra pas
d'agir euh pour atteindre les objectifs
que l'on souhaite pour faire diminuer
drastiquement l'immigration dans notre
pays que ce soit les flux d'arrivé que
ce soit euh les expulsions qui sont
nécessaires pour les étrangers qui se
trouvent en situation irrégulière dans
notre pays dans ce contexte l'Assemblée
nationale s'est saisie du texte et la
commission des lois a travaillé toute la
semaine et je laisserai le soin à Annie
jeunevard qui a été présente jour et
nuit dans cette commission d'en d'en
parler mais je crois qu'on peut d'ors et
déjà adresser un bilan très clair de ce
qui s'apparente pour nous à un
détricotage massif
systématique de toutes les avancées
obtenues par le Sénat la réforme de
l'aide médicale d'État
supprimé les plafonds
migratoires supprimé le débat annuel sur
la politique
migratoire supprimé la réinstallation la
réinstauration du dél de séjour
irrégulier supprimé les mesures de
durcissement du regroupe familial
supprimé le fichier des mineurs non
accompagnés supprimé les conditions
d'application de la double peine
alléger la réforme du Code de la
nationalité considérablement allégé la
caution retour pour les
étudiants supprimé voilà donc on voit
bien que sur tous les points essentiels
la commission des
lois GUID par l'aile gauche de la
majorité a abouti à un texte très
largement
dénaturé reste la question essentiel qui
a qui a fait débat de la
régularisation des étrangers en
situation
irrégulière dans le cadre des
pseudométiers en tension là encore c'est
un véritable droit opposable à la
régularisation que l'Assemblée nationale
a choisi
d'imposer en rétablissant l'accès du
marché du travail pour les demandeurs
d'asile he donc c'est aussi
l'article l'article 4 bis qui a été
totalement
déconstruit et l'initial article 4 du
projet de loi du gouvernement qui
prévoyait pour les demandeurs d'asile de
pouvoir travailler qui a été
réinstallé donc la majorité
gouvernementale a très clairement fait
le choix de ne pas adopter les mesures
nécessaires indispensables
essentiel pour enrayer la profonde crise
migratoire que traverse notre pays nous
avons pu d'ailleurs le constater
avec clarté lorsque nous avons défendu
également en commission c'était mercredi
dernier le 29 novembre notre proposition
de loi
constitutionnelle j'en ai été j'en suis
le rapporteur nous en discuterons demain
matin en séance à l'Assemblée nationale
mais ce qui s'est passé est assez
révélateur des pensées voire des
arrièrespensées du gouvernement et de la
majorité puisque sur les h articles que
contient cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui pour nous est euh
je dirais le le socle d'une véritable
volonté de changement en matière
migratoire sans cela rien ne sera
possible sans cela nous sommes toujours
dans la communication sans cela nous
sommes toujours dans le en même temps
immobile et impuissant qui fait que
d'année en année les flux migratoires
augmentent que plus ils augmentent plus
il y a des lois et plus il y a de lois
plus il y a de flux migratoire c'est ce
que nous connaissons en gros depuis 40
ans et si on n pas moment cette rupture
constitutionnelle et bien nous ne
changerons pas de façon radicale comme
cela est indispensable la situation de
notre pays en matière migratoire mais ce
qui s'est passé est assez révélateur la
majorité a voté sur H articles que
contient notre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle se amendements sur
chacun des articles de suppression
déposée par la France insoumise voilà
dans le contexte où cette France
insoumise montre le visage de de la
haine de l'intolérance de la violence au
sein même de cette commission des lois
pendant les débats avec un député qui
s'en est pris physiquement à un autre
pour l'empêcher de parler et bien la
majorité n'a rien trouvé de mieux la
limite elle aurait pu assumer sa
responsabilité mais de voter la
suppression de notre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle avec les insoumis
voilà je crois que ça traduit aud des
longues analyses juridiques un état
d'esprit une volonté nous avons reçu le
message parfaitement voilà nous nous
nous
disons que en refusant cette
révision qui est pour nous je le redis
j'insiste un préalable indispensable à
toute action déterminée efficace la
majorité a clairement indiqué qu'elle
n'entendait pas se donner les moyens
d'une vraie politique
migratoire dans ce contexte le projet de
loi présenté par Monsieur
Darmanin tel qu'il a été adopté par la
commission des lois n'est qu'un texte au
Rabet un texte sans ambition qui ne
règlera au final rien c'est un texte qui
s'annonce une fois de plus impuissant il
n'est ni à la hauteur des enjeux ni à la
hauteur de la gravité de la situation en
lieu et place d'un indispensable barrage
à l'immigration de masse le projet de
loi ouvre la voie à un éniè appel d'air
migratoire une fois encore le dog du en
même temps conduit à l'impuissance et la
majorité
présidentielle prisonnière de de son
elle gauche nous l'avons bien vécu en
commission se révèle incapable de
répondre avec force avec efficacité aux
angoisses et aux attentes des Français
dans ce contexte je le dis très
clairement et nous le disons et nous le
dirons tous ensemble nous ne serons pas
les complices de cet échec annoncé nous
ne voterons pas le texte du projet de
loi tel qu'il a été adopté par la
commission des lois le vote de ce texte
sera naturellement rendez-vous important
pour notre pays et pour nos concitoyens
or ce n'est pas en votant un texte
impuissant que nous redonnerons aux
Français l'espérance de lendemain
meilleur et de réponse adaptée au
contraire en votant une petite loi sans
avenir sans ambition nous condamnons
quelque part nos compatriotes à la
désespérance et l'action politique tique
à une crise de confiance
redoublée nous appelons donc la majorité
présidentielle à sortir de
l'enchevêtrement de ces contradictions
et à rebâtir un projet de loi
d'immigration digne de ce nom notre
devoir et c'est dans ce sens que nous
conduirons nos débats dans les jours qui
viennent et plus que jamais à l'action
et au refus de l'impuissance immobile
merci
beaucoup
un
question bien bonjour à
tous je voudrais vous dire les
sentiments qui m'animent à l'issu de
cette semaine d'examen du
texte contrôler l'immigration et
favoriser l'intégration puisque c'est le
titre du texte que nous avons eu à à
débattre tout d'abord la conviction que
dans notre pays hélas il est très
difficile de parler de façon
normale en adulte responsable en en élu
convaincu que il y a des choses à dire
en la matière dans notre pays il est
impossible de parler d'immigration de
façon normale le président a rappelé
l'épisode d'un député qui hurlait temps
en commission qu'il voulait couvrir et
empêcher le débat mais pendant l'examen
de la loi institutionnel nous avons été
Éric cotier et moi l'objet
d'insulte parce que nous parlions de
réformes constitutionnelles des droits
qui s'attachent aux étrangers et de la
légitimité pour la France à défendre sa
souveraineté en la matière donc ce
climat ce climat il est tout à fait
regrettable et bien des pays européens
sont à même de pouvoir parler de ces
sujets qui intéressent nos concitoyens
comme le dit souvent Bruno retaillot pas
un phénomène n'a plus modifié
l'environnement des Français que ces 50
dernières années la l'installation d'une
immigration de plus en plus massive
alors contrôler l'immigration pour nous
clairement ça un sens c'est le sens de
la diminuer et je crois que le la
majorité n'a jamais assumé le fait de
vouloir diminuer l'immigration la preuve
en est et sans doute cet article 4 bis
en est-il l'illustration la plus
marquante je je je crois que il nous
faut comprendre pourquoi cet article 4
bis concentre l'essentiel de nos
critiques parce que pour contrôler
l'immigration il faut diminuer les flux
entrants or cet article 4 bis tel qu'il
a été modifié par l'Assemblée nationale
par la commission de l'Assemblée
nationale crée véritablement les
conditions d'une régularisation de droit
la régularisation devient de droit et
quand on sait que le stock d'étranger en
situation irrégulière et considérable
tous les chiffres convergent vers 700 à
900000 personnes dans notre pays et
parmi eux des gens qui
sont concernés par possiblement par
cette régularisation par le travail donc
là il y a une faute majeure s'il y avait
un point éminemment bloquant dans ce
texte de loi ce serait sans doute
celui-là j'ajoute que le gouvernement a
a privé le préfet de son pouvoir
d'appréciation
des situations singulières car
effectivement il y a parfois des
situations singulières où les préfets
peuvent délivrer des titres de séjour à
à titre tout à fait exceptionnel or
demain le droit sera du côté du
demandeur de titre de séjour et pas du
côté du préfet du représentant de l'État
qui avait jusqu'alors la possibilité de
dire oui ou de dire non et pire encore
dans le véau du préfet il y a la menace
à l'ordre public mais la menace à
l'ordre public n'exclut pas les
infractions pénales ça veut dire que
demain vous pouvez avoir un
demandeur un étranger en situation
irrégulière qui obtienneent euh le droit
de travailler un titre de séjour même
s'il est sous le coup d'infraction
pénale ce qui est gravissime et je ne
parle pas des demandeurs d'asile qui
avant même d'avoir obtenu le résultat de
leur demande d'asile pourront désormais
accéder au travail donc il y a euh euh
aucune il n'y a de la part du
gouvernement finalement aucune volonté
de diminuer l'immigration or nous notre
conviction profonde et que il n'y a
qu'en diminuant l'intégration qu'on peut
favor en diminuant l'immigration qu'on
peut favoriser l'intégration euh alors
ce qui est sorti de la commission est
incompréhensible par exemple le
renoncement au délit de séjour
irrégulier ça veut dire que on peut
désormais s'installer dans notre pays
sans autorisation et sans que ce ne soit
un délit c'est proprement
incompréhensible et puis il y a beaucoup
de tiédeur songer que et le président en
a parlé le gouvernement a retoqué le
simple projet d'un fichier des mineurs
non accompagnés délinquant un fichier
donc voyez que Gérald Darmanin a parlé
essentiellement à sa
gauche il voulait obtenir la
bienveillance de la partie gauche de sa
majorité et je pense qu'il se trouve
aujourd'hui devant une
situation qui est pour lui extrêmement
difficile parce que en ayant largement
laissé passer un texte de droite au
Sénat en ayant considérablement réduit
ce texte à l'Assemblée que va-t-il faire
à présent je pense que le en même temps
ne marche pas plus en matière
d'immigration qu'il ne marche dans
d'autres sujets et on en a la la
démonstration très très très rapidement
mais je je crois que
vraiment ce texte on atteint
effectivement la limite du du en même
temps on peut pas en matière
d'immigration faire un texte qui soit et
de droite et de gauche quoi
euh ça ça ne marche pas en matière
d'immigration soit on veut qu'il y ait
moins de flux soit on est prêt à en
accueillir plus on peut pas faire les
deux en même temps ça ne marche pas la
limite c'est évidemment qui Diani cet
article 4 bis qui crée ce droit à la
régularisation qui est une vraie rupture
par rapport à ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
où les préfets peuvent régulariser sans
que un un clandestin puisse se prévaloir
d'un droit à la régularisation ce droit
à la régularisation c'est
vraiment il y a la curiosité de regarder
ce qui s'est fait dans notre histoire en
France en Europe c'est un mantra de la
gauche c'est un mantra de la gauche
c'est une mesure qui a été prise deux
fois dans notre pays en 1980 21 par
François par François mitteran arrivant
au pouvoir euh 130000 personnes sont
régularisées et la deuxème fois c'est en
1997 quand juspin devient premier
ministre 2uxème vague de régularisation
on régularise 80000 personnes quand on
regarde en Europe euh l'autre pays qui a
pratiqué des régularisations enfin il y
en a deux il y a il y a le mouvement 5
étoiles qui fait d régularisation en
Italie euh dans le gouvernement coné et
puis euh et puis l'Espagne
l'Espagne a deux reprises Zapatero en en
2008 qui fait je crois 600000
régularisations et plus récemment Pedro
Sanchez en Espagne qui fait aussi une
loi de régularisation qui ressemble
vraiment mot pour mot à ce que propose
aujourd'hui monsieur Darmanin
c'està-dire c'est 2 ans de résidence il
a un peu 2 ans de résidence et exercé un
métier dans une profession en tension
donc le dispositif d'armanin c'est le
dispositif du gouvernement Sanchez
socialiste espagnol ça n'est rien
d'autre
euh alors Monsieur Darmanin dans ces
débats d'ailleurs est incapable de de de
de se hasarder à vous donner des
chiffres le seul chiffre qui donne c'est
le chiffre don on est sûr qu'il ne sera
pas le bon puisqu'il parle de 7000
régularisations 7000 régularisations
c'est ce qui se fait aujourd'hui alors
qu'il n'y a pas de droit à la
régularisation la réalité c'est quand on
essaie de creuser un peu quand on
regarde les les les données dont on
dispose il y a il y a une étude qui a
été fait par par des chercheurs très
sérieux de l'incerme d'un institut de
recherche sur la santé ldes des
chercheurs de de
Dauphine montre que sur si on a 800000
clandestins les les les les taux qui
sont donnés c'est que
euh à peu près 40 % des clandestins sont
là depuis plus de 3 ans donc ça vous
fait déjà sur 800000 ou 900000 320 à
360000 personnes qui sont dans notre
pays depuis plus de 3 ans donc qui
remplissent une des deux premières
conditions euh la deuxième condition
posée dans le texte c'est d'exercer dans
un métier en tension tous les métiers
sont en tension aujourd'hui regardez il
y a la curiosité de regarder dans nos
régions ce que sont les listes de
métiers en tension pour l'emploi nous
dit que 40 % des des des métiers sont en
tension Durre de catégorie 5 tension
vraiment
absolue voà et le profil des clandestins
là aussi il nous donne une indication
très claire sur le fait que ce sont des
gens qui vraisemblablement ont une
activité selon la même étude que je cite
entre les les clandestins qui ont entre
18 et 40 ans représenteraient 68 % des
clandestins 68 % des clandestin aurait
entre 18 et 40 ans donc sont très
probablement dans une activité
aujourd'hui dans un métier en tenstion
donc cet article Kbis il ouvre un droit
à des une voie à des régularisations
massives euh autre subtilité quand même
apporté par par l'Assemblée nationale
par la commission c'est que ce droit à
la régularisation il est ouvert jusqu'en
2028 c'està-dire que des gens qui ne
sont pas encore en France qui euh allez
seraiit en Guinée et regarderaiit les
débats de l'Assemblée nationale et où on
est la loi d'armanin sur France 24 bien
ils ont tout leur temps pour venir en
France ils auront le temps de se
constituer ses droits d'abord faut
qu'ils deviennent faux demandeur d'asile
ils auront le droit de travailler
immédiatement ils auront le droit de se
d'avoir les 8 mois euh pour pour avoir
la la régularisation et après ils auront
le temps des des 3 ans de s'installer
dans la clandestinité pour être
régularisé ce système il est fou et il
est évidemment totalement inacceptable
pour nous c'est vraiment une ligne rouge
majeure qui suffit malheureusement il y
a tous les autres renoncements qu' voqué
Éric et et Annie mais ce cette mesure là
elle est totalement inacceptable pour
nous
question discours ça va faire beaucoup
euh non mais vous le savez he les 3/4
des Français 74 % des Français
souhaitent qu'il y ait moins
d'immigration ce que veulent les
Français tous les peuples d'Europe le
veulent et quand les gouvernements ne
les entendent pas euh ces peuples
européens trouvent dans les urnes le
moyen justement de réagir c'est ce qui
s'est passé d'ailleurs en Hollande à
chaque fois c'est la même chose il y a
une indexation quand on ne règle pas les
problèmes migratoires avec le vote
populiste puisque je vous rappelle que
en 2022 les Pays-Bas ont accueilli
l'équivalent de 400000 euh immigrés en
plus ramené à la proportion des
habitants français ce serait 1 million 6
les résultats vous les avez comme moi
donc il y a une un enjeu qui est énorme
qui est démocratique puisque mais pas
seulement puisque ERC l'a dit dans son
introduction trop d'immigration une
immigration qui n'est plus du tout
contrôlée c'est le désordre c'est
l'insécurité et c'est un risque de
partition c'est ce que le Sénat a pris
en compte pour faire un texte qui très
honnêtement depuis 30 ou 40 ans a
proposé des mesures comme jamais la
droite n'en avait proposé et qui ont été
voté et qui pour plus de 95 % ces
mesures ont été puisées dans le texte de
loi ordinaire que nous avions déposé
avec Éric et puis et puis Olivier nous
l'avons fait avec plusieurs principes et
deux grands principes que je vais vous
rappeler mais qui ont été très largement
piétiné le premier c'est de contrôler
strictement drastiquement les flux les
entrées les sorties et 2uxème principe
c'est de faire en sorte que la France
cesse d'être le pays le mieux disant sur
un certain nombre de de pompe aspiante
rapidement sur le premier principe les
flux et bien au total on va avoir à la
fois plus de régularisation je ne
reviens pas sur l'article 4 bis
totalement dénaturé par la commission
des lois plus donc d'entrée plus d'appel
d'ire mais il y aura aussi moins
d'expulsion puisque nous avions très
fermement fermé toutes les voies qui
permettent de protéger qui permettent de
créer des exceptions à au principe
d'expulsion
les députés les ont assouplliis donc on
aura à nouveau plus de régularisation et
moins d'expulsion on avait créé à
nouveau puisque fr François Hollande
l'avait supprimé ce délit de séjour
illégal il a été rétabli voilà je pense
que ça c'est quelque chose de
fondamental et il y a d'autres points
mais je veux pas me m'attarder sur ces
points là le deuxième principe ce sont
les pomes aspirant c'est tout ce qui
permet malheureusement à la France
d'être dans le haut du panier et quand
les filières les font leur shopping
dirigent vers tel ou tel pays les flux
migratoires ils se rendent bien compte
que c'est la France qui est la mieux
disante donc sur regroupement familial
là aussi des tricotages y compris je me
souviens c'est essentiellement cette
disposition de la loi Colom en 2018 qui
nous avait fait voter contre ce texte
puisque la loi colon conférait au MNA au
mineurs non accompagné un droit au
regroupement familial il a été rétabli
donc en matière de regroupement familial
on fait à nouveau fonctionner cette
pompe aspirante les soins aussi laame
bien entendu et on pourra parler tout à
l'heure si vous souhaitez du rapport de
Monsieur Evin monsieur Stéfanini mais au
moins ils reconnaissent dans ce rapport
que cela nous met en tête de tous les
pays européens et sans doute du monde
entier voilà et que ça entretient
d'ailleurs et que ça maintient que c'est
une aide au maintien de l'immigration
clandestine y compris d'ailleurs pour le
titre de pour les étrangers malades là
encore on a le meilleur régime qui était
considérablement resserré par le fermaat
par le Sénat et réouvert par l'Assemblée
nationale même chose sur le droit
d'asile Olivier en a parlé Annie en on
parlé aussi l'article 4 c'est quoi c'est
de donner l'accès au marché du travail
sur les demandeurs d'asile dès le
premier jour la moyenne européenne c'est
entre 9 et 6 mois la directive c'était 9
il y a un grand groupe de pays qui sont
à 9 mois l'autre groupe qui est à 6 mois
on y était jusqu'à présent et nous on
sera au premier jour ça nous classe
encore à l'avant-garde garde des pays
européens l'accès à la nationalité nous
avions réintroduit bien d'autres choses
mais par exemple le dispositif passoir
pour que un enfant né en France de
parents étrangers ne devienne pas par
hasard français qui est véritablement
une adhésion un consentement à le
devenir et ça a été balayé d'un revers
de main donc grand détricotage 31
articles sur le plan quantitatif qui
manque et et surtout une cohérence
d'ensemble qui a été totalement
détruite très Franch j'aiétais surpris
je suis parlementaire depuis quelques
années et je sais parfaitement que quand
vous partez d'un texte en commission qui
est à ce point mauvais affaibli c'est
très très très difficile quoi qu'on en
pense quoi qu'on veuille de le rétablir
dans sa plénitude en séance publique
c'est l'expérience parlementaire qui
vous la prend donc au vu de ce texte il
est hors de question évidemment si
jamais ce texte était tel qu'el voté en
séance publique impossible d'avoir voir
notre accord en commission mixte
paritaire impossible de le voter
initialement et je doute très fortement
aujourd'hui parce que l'écart est
tellement grand il est habissal entre le
texte qui sort de la commission présidée
par Monsieur Houlier et tous les efforts
tous les amendements qui feraient
rétablir pour redonner sa cohérence sa
force à ce texte en séance publique je
doute vraiment que la majorité par
ailleurs divisé soit en mesure de le
faire on va répondre à vos questions si
vous en
avez c'est la
complicité je reprendrai pas le terme
mais
s'abstenir sur un texte en l'état n'est
absolument
pas dans envisager et en tout cas
personnellement je m'y refuse j'ai dit
les choses très clairement le texte de
la commission des lois tel qu'il ressort
de la commission des lois ne mérite
qu'une opposition claire et
forte ma question unu dans ce sens
est-ce que vous avez des conditions qui
ser
aujourd'hui dans la continuité de la de
la question qui vient d'être posée
est-ce qu'il y a des conditions vous
dites dans dans la discussion qu'on va
avoir en hémicycle si c certaines
avancées vont dans votre sens est-ce
queil y a des possibilités une marge
d'arriver à cette abstention sous
certaines conditions où aujourd'hui elle
est vraiment quoi qu'il arrive exclu
nous ce que nous disons c'est le texte
du Sénat rien que le texte du Sénat et
tout le texte du Sénat voilà mais il y a
déjà des impossibilités à réintroduire
le texte du Sénat parce que la majorité
enlever des pans entiers de discussions
notamment sur la
laame au motif ce que nous contestons
que le débat sur l'ame n'aurait aucun
lien avec l'immigration c'est quand même
intellectuellement euh assez difficile à
tenir cette position mais donc tous les
amendements qui permettrai en séance de
réintroduire laame euh seront déclarés
euh de de réformer laame vers la mu tel
que cela avait été prévu au Sénat seront
déclarés irrecevables il anné de même
sur la nationalité comment là aussi ne
pas considérer que le code de la
nationalité a un impact très direct sur
les flux migratoires Bruno rotaillot en
parlait d'autant qu'il y a un article
qui concerne Mayotte et qui évoque les
questions de
nationalité d'acquisition de la
nationalité française à Mayotte il en
est de même sur les mineurs non
accompagnés comment ne pas
voir un lien très direct entre ces flux
migratoires et
euh la situation des ce qu'on appelle
pudiquement ces mineurs non accompagnés
qui sont très souvent des clandestins
adultes d'ailleurs voilà encore cette
nuit dans ma ville à Nice il y a eu des
tirs au quartier des Moulins il y a eu
des interpellations et les personnes
interpellées étaient des mineurs non
accompagnés il est arrivé en Italie
c'est un chiffre du mois d'octobre
15336 mineurs non non accompagnés voilà
donc qu'il y a cette situation et on n
parle pas donc si on ne parle pas euh
des pompes aspirantes si on ne parle pas
des conditions social on a oublié
d'évoquer aussi dans les modifications
euh le fait que le Sénat avait introduit
c'est un point essentiel euh le fait de
d'imposer une présence obligatoire de 5
an sur le territoire national avant de
bénéficier de prestations sociales non
contributive ça particip là aussi de la
fin de ce modèle extraordinairement
généreux et donc extraordinairement naïf
donc tous ces points pour certains sur
l'article 4 bis sur le délit de séjour
nous allons les réintroduire nous allons
tenter de les réintroduire par
amendement je doute que la majorité est
une position différente de celle qu'elle
a eu très massivement en commission des
lois pour le reste une partie des débats
ont déjà été interdits quasiment de
façon procédurale et ça pour nous ça
restera quoi qu'il arrive un texte
inachevé inabouti incomplet et donc
impuissant
bonjour bonjour thomaspr pour RTL qui
qui s'abstiendront est-ce qu'ils auront
des sanctions sur ce texte est-ce que il
y aura des des exclusions par exemple
pour le président du groupe monsieur le
Président group non écoutez on raisonne
pas comme ça al l'heure d'aujourd'hui je
vois pas beaucoup de députés au sein du
groupe qui sont prêts à valider un
mouvement de régularisation massive une
fois encore je vous dis c'est un mantra
de la gauche dans notre histoire je vois
pas beaucoup de députés LR prêt à faire
ce
choix vous ne voyez pas beaucoup de
députés LR prêt à le faire mais on sait
qu'il y en a qu'il y en a certains qui
vont le faire enfin on ça dépendra bien
sûr des débats dans l'hémicycle mais
plus que même alors c'est
formidable alors bah vous dites
vous-même que voilà vous vous n'avez pas
utilisé une une formule qui qui dit
l'ensemble de mon groupe va voter contre
ce texte donc ce texte c'est un peu de
nouveau un test pour votre groupe un
test d'unité certains vont même voter
pour Monsieur camine non
écoutez je je je comprends le petit jeu
qui consiste de de la part de de de
l'exécutif de la part de cette majorité
qui de la part du président de la
République qui ne supporte pas d'être en
quelque sorte mis sous tutelle de
l'assemblée et d'être un peu sous la
tutelle du groupe des Républicains de
absolument vouloir décrédibiliser les
républicains en expliquant que nous
serions nous serions divisés
euh nous avons à la dernière réunion de
groupe très clairement réaffirmer une
position ça a été voté à l'unanimité sur
le fait que nous n'accepterions aucun
détricotage du texte du Sénat euh que
nous n'accepterions aucun
euh aucune disposition permettant un
droit à la régularisation je vois pas
comment on peut l'exprimer plus
clairement après si des gens ont des
problèmes de cohérence interne c'est à
eux qu'il faut poser la question mais
euh cette ce ce ce cette position a été
réaffirmée de manière totalement unanime
j'ajoute s'agissant de maotte on est
quand même sur une question très
singulière donc vous ne pouvez pas tirer
conclus fusion du vote d'un
député sur l'ensemble de du vote il s'en
est expliqué de manière extrêmement
amicale hier en réunion de groupe en
disant que la singularité de la
situation de Mayotte la la la détresse
des habitants de Mayotte faisait que il
est obligé de prendre toutes mesures
vous savez que notre Constitution permet
de l'adaptation du droit à maotte et
donc les mesures spécifique à maotte
euh voilà sont sont sont nécessaires et
sont possibles malheureusement euh le
gouvernement ne prend pas le même chemin
pour la France
métropolitaine bonjour Paul Bria pour
l'Agence France Presse la FP est-ce que
vous entendez déposer une motion de
rejet sur ce projet de loi immigration
et si oui quand écez on a on a jusqu'à
midi et demi pour le faire on verra euh
voilà on n a pas on voilà on verra c'est
pas on ver bah d'ici 12h et30 on
comptait en parler un peu avec Eric tout
à l'heure donc on vous dira pardon ça
pourra changer on vous dira ça vous
savez que le problème des mootion de
rejet c'est qu'il y a un tirage au sort
donc on n jamais sûr qu'elle soit
qu'elle soit qu'elle soit retenue on
peut être sûr si dépose ou pas ouais
vous surez ça à midi écart le
principérence de press poser des
questions des réponses ouis vous serez
ça midicart
voilà bonjour vous disiez votre surprise
tout à l'heure que la majorité se met en
soutien de certains amendement en
commission de la France insoumise ce
matin Gérard Larcher a tenu un propos
qui est très commenté en réaction à ce
que à la polémique soulevée par les
propos de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce
weekend sur l'une de nos
concers qu'est-ce que vous comment vous
comprenez cette colère de Gérard Larché
et est-ce qu'un président du Sénat doit
s'exprimer comme
ça je non seulement je comprends mais
j'approuve voilà
euh et je crois qu'il a parfaitement
résumé je crois que le politiquement
correct par rapport à des gens qui
veulent détruire la République qui ont
un projet révolutionnaire qui veulent
saper nos institution qui ont même
introduit la violence physique dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
n'appelle qu'une réaction claire elle
est claire et pour moi elle est non
seulement pertinente mais c'est un cap à
tenir bonjour Victor à Libération est-ce
que la motion est-ce que le d'une motion
de censure est toujours à l'ordre du
jour vous devriez écouter davantage ce
que dit la première ministre qui s'est
engagé devant les Français à ne plus
utiliser le 493 et écoutez ce que dit le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui dit qu'il ne
veut pas de 493 donc s'il y a pas de 493
la question que vous posez est nulle et
non
avenue moi je souhaite qu'on aille au
vote je je je la première ministre a dit
qu' ne voulait pas passer en force en
dehors des textes budgétaires sur
lesquels elle n pas d'autres alternative
et le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
répond RBI orbi qu'il aura une
majorité grâce à des alliances un peu
partout le li groupeotte et
éventuellement des amitiés ailleurs
écoutez s'ils sont si sûrs que ça de la
qualité de leur texte et du fait que que
ce texte est aussi
séduisant qu'ils aillent au vote
hein bien on va peut-être conclure merci
pour votre présence je rajouterai que
nous défendrons donc demain matin la
proposition de loi
constitutionnelle et qu'en tant que
rapporteur je défendrai un amendement
qui installe dans la
constitution des dispositions de sûreté
en matière de prévention du du
terrorisme hein nous permettront par
cette modification si elle était adoptée
de prendre des dispos des dispositions
relatives à la rétention de sûreté ou à
la rétention administrative pour les
individus connus identifié par les
services de renseignement dont la
dangerosité est avérée qui sortte
quelquefois de de prison et qui sont
identifiés comme étant des bombes
humaines potentielles on l'a vu encore
dans l'attentat qui est intervenu ce
weekend aux abord
de la tour effffel symbole au combien de
notre de notre
nation nouvelle fois cet individu était
parfaitement identifié connu comme l'a
souligné Olivier marlex hier à
l'Assemblée nationale sa mère avait même
sollicité les services de police pour
souligner sa dangerosité
euh nous sommes aujourd'hui dépourvu des
outils qui pourraient assurer une plus
grande protection pour nos concitoyens
il y a deux manières de le faire soit
installer l'état d'urgence qui offre des
dispositions d'assignation à résidence
et de
perquisition
administrative qui
sont puissantes soit et c'est ce que
nous souhaitons ce que j'ai défendu
personnellement depuis plusieurs années
de voir depuis plus de 10 ans depuis le
début de la vague terroriste qui a causé
près de 300 victimes dans notre pays que
nous ayons des dispositifs à l'égal de
ceux qui avaient été fait pour les
pédocriminels sous la présidence de
Nicolas Sarkozi qui permettent de placer
ces individus dangereux hors d'état de
nuir dans des structures de suivi adapté
sous contrôle judiciaire euh notamment
bien entendu dans le cadre de notre état
de de droit mais dans un état de droit
qui s'adapte à une menace qui est de
plus en plus forte et qui sera
extrêmement
importante à la veille et pendant les
Jeux Olympiques donc ne soyons pas naïf
dans cette période dotons-nous des
outils les mieux
adaptésgéous RA pour
souz cet accord qui date de 19
8 offre des droits aux
ressortissants algériens notamment en
matière de séjours qui sont totalement
exorbitants il n'y a aucune raison qu'il
y ait un privilège algérien au séjour
qui est des conditions d' d'octroit de
de titre de résidence qui soi très
largement facilité par rapport à
d'autres
nationalités je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
est temps que l'Algérie et que la
relation avec l'Algérie rentre dans un
droit commun il y a aujourd'hui une
immigration algérienne extrêmement forte
et nous notons en contre-partie sur
l'octroi des laissés passer consulaires
qui sont le préalable à toute politique
d'éloignement et d'exécution des otf
qu'il n'y a aucune volonté positive de
la part des autorités algériennes bien
au contraire on est à quelques dizaines
à peine de laisser passer consulaire par
rapport aux milliers de demandes qui
sont formulées par le ministère de
l'Intérieur donc une relation
diplomatique elle repose sur une
réciprocité l'Algérie ne cesse
d'insulter les autorités françaises euh
dans ce contexte plus encore il n'y a
aucune légitimité à ce que il y ait ce
privilège euh issu de l'histoire qui
perdure et qui favorise là aussi des
flux migratoires massifs venus de
l'Algérie merci c'est une façon de
rappeler aussi la relativité de la